our guest today is filmmaker Todd Hickey
his credits include as a cinematographer
after sex Sonny Boy and freestyle the
art of the rhyme he made his directorial
debut with this past year's wrestling
gem takedowns and falls which we
screened this past October at our film
courage interactive we had a great crowd
there I'm at the event and Kara I know
you you loved all the people sort of
pouring in you know what with the Q&A
questions yeah and little kids I just
remember there was this eight-year-old
boy in the audience and he was just so
excited and he he was asking questions
so it was a fun night had a great I know
and the man here today impressed us with
his ability to fine
to go out and find his audience and then
get to meet ask them to the theater
please welcome to the film courage
studio mr. Todd Hickey hello how's it
going oh it's great great having you
here yeah yeah we're having a good time
here Todd it's been nice chatting with
you outside the studio here and that now
gets in here and you know we've been
excited to do this for a while yeah you
guys do a lot of great stuff for
filmmakers like us think oh we
appreciate that thank you
so let's find out about your background
now we understand that you wrestled a
bit in high school I did I did I wasn't
a very good wrestler but I actually
wrestled for Coach Swaggart who is one
of the main characters in the film and
it's part of the genesis of the film
Kirk ledger and I my producing partner
in it both went to high school together
we went to film school together we
always wanted to fill a gap that we saw
in documentary films that there really
wasn't the film like this you know too
many films that just covered sort of a
season of high school wrestling and your
average wrestling team well I think in
another interview you said witnesses
your quote that you were an
underachiever and then you got to
college and you kind of regretted
missing out on your wrestling days and
couldn't go back so this fueled you it
did it did absolutely I think that a lot
of us growing up are afraid to try and
it's easier to fail and think they you
know oh well I didn't really try that
hard so you move on you know and that's
something that drives me as a filmmaker
to really put everything into it you
know and like coach market always has no
excuses so
you said you went to film school was
that your first experience with
filmmaking or were you making short
films as a kid no film school was my
first experience I took pictures had
some photography classes really enjoyed
photography but at some point just
decided that I wanted to try to make
films and and and went to Temple
University you know where that came from
Todd where did this urge to go to film
school just as an audience member I
think part of it was do the right thing
seeing do the right thing in the theater
and like it just affected me like I want
to tell stories I want to tell a
personal story you know and that like we
all have stories to tell and how do we
do it how do we get that message out
there but you weren't one of those 10
year old kids with a camcorder in his
hand going out filming the block and you
know I wasn't I wasn't going off I was
out getting any trouble probably you
know it and once you get to Temple
University you're in the film school
program there you know what what kept
you persisting I feel making what what
would you know what I mean you did you
literally catch sort of the the bite I
did I mean I was interested in writing
too and I think just storytelling I
found my niche in cinematography like
shot my own projects and everybody else
in film school wanted me to shoot those
theirs so then it was sort of just the
path of least resistance it's like well
you're close to the director you're part
of the storytelling you technically
you're really involved in the process
you know and I just wanted to master as
many departments as I could and and that
was an easy way for me to be on a lot of
sets with with the important role yeah
you know I love hearing this stuff this
is film Corelli talk radio calm
we're in studio with filmmaker Todd
Hickey something we want to Bree we just
want I want to touch on something here
because you know in doing research saw
that you came up with the story for a
new Nicolas Cage Guy Pearce film you
know you're given story credit on this
what was the evolution of development
there
you know is it a story that you pitched
to the studios no my friend Robert
Tannen who is this green who wrote the
screenplay it's like a coffee shop buddy
of mine you know we commiserate over our
Hollywood Life and it's in the struggles
within and one day we're just trading
stories and I told him about this idea I
had and and then he reached asked me if
he could write it into a screenplay
which he did and and then through his
manager and agent
they say sold the script Wow so I didn't
really have much to do with the process
after the idea after the idea Wow well
how does that feel for you see you
seeing this idea that you had it is
going on to become that you know a
pretty big film here it's I mean it's
cool of course but it's taken so long we
sold it years ago three years ago and
it's done it's been done for a while I'm
not sure when it's coming out hopefully
late this fall or something but you know
I had heard it was gonna come out in the
spring and then it didn't so you know
until it's actually in theaters it
doesn't feel totally real okay we're
gonna talk about takedowns and Falls
here before we do Todd I want to
actually turn the Karen first Anna and I
want to ask you Karen are you a
wrestling fan well you know we know you
know me David I'm not a sports fan you
know I didn't grow up dad or brothers
but I love this film it's more than a
wrestling movie though there's a real
heart and soul to it and you become
interested in each you know subject for
lack of a better word and in finding out
about their life and their struggles so
no I'm not a sports fan but I do love
this film you see yeah no see I knew it
cuz I you know she she kind of knew
where I was going before I went all the
way there and in terms of you don't have
to be a wrestling fan to really love
this film not to say that it's not for
wrestling fans but but there's something
here or something more here you know
there's this coming-of-age story that
that's really wonderful to watch on the
screen and also I'd argue I you know I
really think this is as much coach
swaggered story as anything as much as
any you know because you know you kind
of said he's one of the main characters
here but I really you know I really
argue it's really his
it is I think he really drives the film
because he drives all the other
characters he's sort of what motivates
the team you know both as many coaches
do and end with his illness and in the
way that he approaches life having
cancer in the film you know and I think
the kids learn a lot from that and and
absolutely grow up right in front of the
cameras we were really fortunate someone
told us once that we caught lightning in
a bottle Wow and I and I think that's an
accurate an accurate phrase you know and
I think also behind the scenes to just
your relationship you know that you and
Keith were former you know wrestlers
under in a Keith was over I'm sorry Kirk
Kirk was a former wrestler for Coast
Swaggart you know you can kind of see
that that relationship happening behind
the scenes as well one thing I really
took away and I don't want to give away
too much about the film but with the
coach his attitude really was like don't
feel sorry for yourself like I meant
remember one scene he's like if someone
else is better than you and it's because
you're out of shape well that's on you
and he really kind of instilled that in
a tough love kind of way it's just like
feeling sorry for yourself is not it's
not okay right there's no way to go
about life yeah yeah and in you know
these wrestling as we all know it until
recently with like UFC there's there's
no like dangling carrot of professional
leagues and that's part of like why
we're so interested in telling wrestler
stories because it's it is what it is
and you know and it's life it just is
what it is you know and there's never
this like all this extra thing to drive
me and wrestling it's when it's over
it's over and if you don't do what you
set out to do
then it's quickly too late you know and
and all a lot of us learn that too late
work through something in life for like
I didn't do what I should have done and
it didn't put into it what I could have
at the time I had excuses you know and
that's what he drives through these kids
before we get into the specifics give us
an overview of how many years did you
have to put in to take down some falls
we started putting it together the
summer of 2006 March of 2006 Walter
peplum and that
other sort of main character of the film
that had been a state runner-up as a
sophomore and coach Swaggart as you
learned in the film was a state
runner-up at Central Dolphin where he
coaches now and so Kirk and I were like
maybe this is the time that's a great
place to start like the best kid on the
team the coach they're both state
runner-ups the school had never won a
state title that region had never won a
team state title you know we're like
maybe this is a this is the place to
start so that's that's where we started
with this like rocky to sort of thing
and then we shot the 2006-2007 season
seems like everything was lining up for
you but can you tell us all the work
that you had put in did it almost not
happen with the film well I mean we we
certainly like other films run and ran
into a lot of stumbling blocks we went
out there and we shot a trailer and and
sort of put that together and then came
back and raised bunny and then had to
raise money completely throughout the
process as we were going we're always
chipping away at you know like oh we
need this we need this we need this and
then and just spending it you know
because it money goes out easier than it
comes in that's for sure oh sure so what
would you do in those times when kind of
the floor fell out from underneath you
how did you keep motivating yourself
just the team around us you know we all
just kept knowing that like once we had
shot got this film in a can we knew we
had to tell this story you know like we
were so lucky we went into it like
looking at it more like something like
spellbound a mosaic of Pennsylvania
wrestling and then we we got to CD and
started to meet the kids or you know the
other kids on the team like Tony to
Lagos Simon Rice Kenny stank who's has
diabetes you know another great
character that's motivating himself and
we're like look we just have to stay
here and coach gave us so much access
you know that it was just like let's
just stay here we can't we need like
four or five camera crews around the
state to do sort of what we showed up
here thinking we would do and then that
that decision paid off for us immensely
just by spending so much time with that
one team we're
fortunate to capture the story that we
did do we just dive a little bit deeper
you know into the development of this
site because you had the idea you saw
like it's right there in front of you
you know what was the prep work you know
I mean because you have to go there
you're gonna talk to the coaches do you
start talking to the to the
student-athletes their families I mean
how much before you could actually roll
cameras on this story yeah you know and
did it almost fall through that you know
even though the window was open no I
mean not I don't think it almost fell
through more than any other documentary
like this you know like we knew that we
wanted to do it and we were gonna keep
trying I mean Kirk and I are both from
Harrisburg so we both stayed at our
parents houses you know I destroyed my
dad's truck using it throughout the
production you know and it was family
and friends that kept us going and when
when it felt like the bottom might drop
out but as far as prep work we basically
wrote a treatment then we reached out to
coach Swaggart he reached out to the
school for us and sort of gave us the
thumbs-up and then we went out there and
met with the peppermint's and that was
the first family that we met with with
Walters parents and Marshalls parents
and then and then we went to a coach
parent night for the team and talked to
the whole like all the parents that
showed up about what we wanted to do and
they all were okay with it the school
was okay with it and then we started
shooting and what was what was their
reaction I mean was this something they
were resistant to you know and warmed up
to or did you have their full enthusiasm
right away um I think it was there I
don't think there was resistance but
people were concerned you know in the in
the world of reality television and
everybody wants to tell bad stories you
know like bad news and this is what
these kids are doing wrong there was
concern of like what do they want to
tell like what story do they want to
tell these kids partying you know like
reality has a lot of you know different
versions you know so I think that they
were concerned more than anything but
you know we we just stayed on course and
and just and they didn't do
and and and I think eventually they
figured out who Kirk and I were and then
we had good intentions and how about the
kids how did they react there were some
of them oh yeah I want to be a star type
of a thing and others were more shy well
I think you see in the film some of them
are hams and some were resistant to the
cameras absolutely you know not not
resistant but but you know like some
kids don't like being on camera and and
you know if the movie starts with Walt
saying that he doesn't like to be the
center of attention but he's the star of
the team it was one of the best kids in
the state and there's that conflict sir
you know throughout the film and we're
making a film on a kid that says and it
does not want to be the center of
attention in a sport where you're
absolutely the center of attention one
at a time so you know there it was
tricky it was tricky at times you know
Walt's a great kid and he was great to
us but we wanted him to be himself and
you know part of him being himself was
to not engage with the camera absolutely
at any time well how did you get him to
trust you then and how did you get him
to kind of let down his guard a little
bit cuz he did great I mean you're so
drawn in by a story but in knowing that
just by being there the time we were
there every day we talked to him at all
the kids every day shared stories you
know just by being around good showing
them that we were dedicated you know
whatever practice they had we were gonna
be at you know we traveled and we shared
our still our experiences of being kids
yeah you know and what I guess what was
it like each day I mean you know so
you're there for every practice for
every match is that right yeah and and
so when they arrived after school for
practice are you there with your cameras
like set up and rolling pretty much yeah
we my rolling coach we plant mics and
the mats and you know stuff like that
yeah when we say how it's your day you
know we like those guys we became
friends that you know this movie so they
knew like not only were they going
directly wrestling practice but they
were being documented as well yeah that
was part of the process yeah for sure
you know when you're watching these
stories unfold on the screen you find
yourself becoming the viewer more and
more personally invested and I'm sure
this is just a fraction of your
experience what we see
when you finish the filming how hard was
it for you to leave this team I mean you
must have felt this huge emptiness oh
for sure I mean I think one of my
biggest lessons making this film was how
hard it was to like edit the film
knowing that the people in it we're
gonna see it you know again because like
no one asked to be in this film no you
know and we portrayed people honestly
but sometimes honesty hurts you know
like Doug's character for example I mean
you know I felt I was scared I was
scared to be completely honest you know
because I don't want to hurt anybody's
life you know or feelings you know so
that was quite difficult it's hard you
know sit it's ask some of the questions
because for those that haven't seen the
film it we don't want to necessarily go
all the way there um but but let's let's
come here did you're gonna go ahead and
make this film where does the initial
money come from cuz I cuz I don't know
the timeframe like you've met with them
in the summer time and you're filming in
the fall yeah it's a fall winter spring
sport but yes so the initial money came
from my friend URI Henley and Park part
of URI is the genesis of this film too
he grew up here in Los Angeles knows
nothing about wrestling we were sitting
down one day talking about you know what
what I'm gonna do next you know just as
a friend a friend he produces a lot of
meat commercials and and movies and
stuff and I was like well you know that
wrestling thing I've always been talking
about maybe we could do something on
that Walter just was runner up he's like
that sounds like a great idea let's
write it up
so URI paid for us to go out there and
make the trailer and he made the initial
investment and and pretty much was
always gap financing the film like
whenever we couldn't find someone else
he you know came up with money somehow
someway for the film it would have never
gotten made without him or my
ex-girlfriend who also did a lot of gap
financing for the film one thing too I
found interesting was that a lot of
these boys in the film that would they
were from these upper-middle class homes
and some of them had their own wrestling
studio in the family's house
how do you think that this set of boys
with the set of wrestlers differed from
an inner-city group or more of a poor
rural group do you think that this had
sort they had less motivation or maybe
more so to live up to family
expectations I think it's different you
know some of some of the kids on the
team don't have the pressure of they
need a college scholarship yeah and like
that that that doesn't play into it you
know but there's a lot of like personal
motivation you know there's a lot of
family pressure that goes on a lot you
know I mean all parents want their kids
to succeed you know but especially in
the upper-middle class yeah for sure
yeah so I mean there's a tremendous
amount of pressure and the kids at some
point started putting that pressure on
themselves you know and and coping with
pressure I think is a great lesson for
kids to be learning you know but I think
kids in the inner city have a different
sort of pressure and I think that that's
why wrestling isn't huge in the inner
city and it's not even huge in the
suburbs it's it's you know it really
comes from like coal mining communities
and farm communities in Pennsylvania
where those kids needed to get to
college you know that's why
traditionally they say Pennsylvania is
so good and wrestling it generated its
Genesis's from those communities now
somehow its popularity has taken off in
this in in more suburban areas you know
you you ended up with with over 500
hours of footage you know believe that
you spent more than two years editing
the film for anyone making a documentary
or even even a narrative that has more
than a hundred hours of footage should
they expect should you expect that
you're going to keep the same editor
from start to finish
no can you comment a little bit about
about your experience here
yeah shooting the film was much easier
than editing it for sure I mean it was a
much more pleasant experience you know
but and it gets it gets difficult you
know like that much time on a film and
that obviously it doesn't pay a lot of
if it takes a lot of time and it takes a
lot of energy and it you know takes your
heart and people get burned out and sick
of each other you know and and move on
you know and it's fine I think it's part
of the process you know you experience
things like that try to learn from it
and do better the next time around that
was the whole idea with this film in the
beginning it's it's not the last film
I'm ever gonna make a hope you know yeah
you know I'm not sure if we see enough
of that I'm not sure if we see enough
filmmakers saying like having the game
plan from the very beginning to say you
know what this is gonna be a monster
project and and I and I and I just know
going in I'm not just gonna rely on one
editor to think they you know although
although that that's important but I
know like with with Tree of Life
I mean Terrence Malick I believe he has
four or five editors on that project
that he knew going in we're gonna go
from one editor to the next and then
we're gonna take that the main editor is
gonna kind of come back on the end and
we're gonna do that that final polished
together right I don't know if I had the
foresight of that they was gonna go down
like this that's why I'm just throwing
it out there for everyone listening oh
we you know but it certainly happened
that way and and I think just the way we
sort of set up that some of the you know
some of the people that had come on as
assistant editors did so much work and
had so much influence on the film and
actually were editors that they deserved
credit to you know and then that's part
of it too it's like well you've
participated so much your mark is on
this film do you deserve a credit to you
know yeah so I mean that's part of the
list of editors also you know like some
left some ran yeah it's tricky it's
tricky you know we've gone through that
with with night before the wedding we
had it where that get a couple different
editors involved you know we're very
very fortunate on our film goodbye
promise that we've had an editor from
from start to finish that kind of took
it from my hands and and stayed on it
you know yeah our guy art Lewis thank
goodness are you focused on building
these relationships with community
leaders is that sort of where you put
your effort into marketing yeah I mean I
think we find a lot of value in like
co-op being audiences
and sharing audiences and and we have a
common cause like us and Scott that
coach and us and you know we co-op ads
with like wrestling websites and stuff
like that we go and shoot little things
for the web sites and then they give us
ad space you know we and that's been
really helpful when you don't have like
a ton of cash you just have to find ways
to get the word out you know and and and
we've been pretty successful in doing
that you know the wrestling community
has embraced the film which you know is
great for us so you know word spreads
it's really just about our reach we see
it all the time every time we get like
like you guys pushing the this this
interview are our DVD sales go up you
know it's really easy to see so it's
just about our reach and the more we
reach and the more we continue to push
then the better that the film keeps
going you know it's taking on a life of
its own oh yeah you have ass intrigue
that have you seen a little increase in
DVD sales with just just with the coming
on this show already oh yeah yeah I mean
like the here we are always looking for
you know I mean if you see our fan page
like it's primarily become like
wrestling news we just recycle wrestling
news it's like because that's what the
fans will keep coming to the page for
and you know people are like just
learning about the film still even
within that community because we don't
have a huge PNA budget and you know the
tour that we did of the Northeast last
year well 2010 you know reach there
certain community but the one good thing
about like sports films is every year
there's new audience members because
every year there's new wrestlers you
know every year there's a new family
that has a kid that wants to wrestle or
play football or play basketball you
know that and we're counting on that
that the film will have legs you know
because it is kind of timeless you know
we actually went through and took some
of the year dates out of the text just
to like take away that like like time
stamping it so much that's interests and
is interesting yeah and I really like
you you you throwing out the term
co-opting the audience I really like
that and and I guess that's part of your
background can you can you talk about
the tour you know that you had previous
to takedowns and falls yeah I used to
run with Kevin Fitzgerald who directed
freestyle the art of rhyming Kevin Epps
who made a film called Straight Outta
Hunter's Point about the San Francisco
community the three of us together put
on a tour with other filmmakers we did
like 30 or 40 cities over a couple of
years in the early 2000s called the hip
hop Film Festival and traveled with that
scratch dark days like showed outfox we
would rent films that that we thought
were important to the hip-hop community
too and sort of all the idea was
everyone promote their own film and each
others you know and it went pretty well
but then our lives sort of became to
being a Film Festival and where everyone
wanted to be filmmakers you know and
that's a conflict in self distribution
or hybrid distribution have happened to
me again last year as Kirk and I weren't
making films we were putting out a film
you know and that's what a lot of
filmmakers want is just to give their
film to someone else to put out and the
risk you run is no one seeing it right
and you sort of you've taken that idea
and and you have that you know you
mentioned you you've gone across the
country with takedowns and Falls you
know how many screenings have you had I
know you haven't done as much screenings
recently but but altogether can you just
give an estimate of how many screenings
you've had well we did 30 cities and
some of the cities we did a lot of
screenings you know like three or four a
day we were renting theaters and mega
plexus we were you know screening right
beside avatar you know because we want
people to take us seriously and audience
members don't know who booked the
theater they have no idea nor do they
care how that film got in that theater
it's there it becomes more real to them
and who was booking the movie that me
and Curt just the two of you we just
called theaters and like you know said
you know wrestling's really popular in
the neighborhood that your theater is in
and they're like sure and then let us do
it you know and all those screenings how
many of them with money losers and how
many of them
profitable probably 50/50 okay wow
that's that's great I mean we did a lot
of for well I mean we've tried to stay
away from fall for wiling the for
wallings of the most dangerous right
view and we got blizzard in Ohio and
that was a tough one so a couple of
cities that we had for Walt you know
which means that we paid for it straight
up but we got all the money back versus
like doing a split with the theater
which is a much safer gamble if you
don't have big audiences you know so one
bad screening in a four wall can set you
back so you were able to arrange with
the megaplex is split deals with with
with larger theater chains yeah yeah I
mean there's so many like little theater
chains you know that like have like five
or six theaters in like you know five
four or five cities that are far enough
apart that that it's different cities
you know that that will work with you
they'll work with you you know it's just
it's a lot of work and a lot of people
don't want to do that work now would you
show up with some of the screenings
would you do Q&A afterwards oh yeah we
traveled with them with Kirk and I drove
around and we went to there were some
that we were doing at the same time
we're in two different cities which
really is valuable I mean if you can get
in a couple of markets at the same time
it really helps you know because the
buzz just just spins off itself but yeah
we went to every screening some of the
cities we would leave you know we would
go for the first day and then leave go
to another city something like that were
you able to get the theaters on Fridays
and Saturday nights or were these more
like weekday some of them it depends
like in the Harrisburg area we were know
like in the films home in places that
felt like they were real wrestling hot
beds that knew right away like yeah we
have a wrestling community here we have
you know people will get behind this and
what did your pitch consist of I mean
you know isn't it just an email is you
know is it letting them know like hey
we're going to be there were so that
sort of what goes into the pitch it was
all that we would email them then call I
mean it it at times took like good cop
bad cop you know like both of us calling
and trying to convince them
just like but we've done this before
like I promise you know look at this and
look at this and what we did here
inquiring the the press clippings and
sending the clippings yeah and I mean
did you did you have like in any
pictures of like sold-out audiences and
saying like here here's what we can do
for you guys a little bit well we did a
few like sneak preview screenings in
Pennsylvania like in Harrisburg that
went really well that we were able to
sort of spin off that success to the
theaters you know it you know it as part
of the theatrical run I mean how how
much importance or how much of a role
did you place on film festivals was was
that it was that part of part of what
you were doing here at all well not
really we had a timeline we wanted to
stick to and then to which was to get
the DVD out by March of the year we were
putting out March last year because
that's like the end of the wrestling
season and we knew that you know if we
didn't have it out by then it would be
until the next wrestling season that
everyone's going to the web forums and
on those Facebook pages on those
Facebook groups and you know what I mean
that like that the awareness drops off
out off season so it was important for
us to do this these screenings leading
up to that to the end of March that year
that's interesting so when did the tour
begin we did it basically November 2009
through March of 2008 of 2010 okay and
then did spot screenings last summer and
then the screening with then we did some
West Coast screenings last fall with you
guys and then up north okay so you
literally wanted to tie in the wrestling
season to the theatrical run and then
while the buzz was still worth their
while the interest was still there you
wanted to release the DVD right at the
tail end of that yes you could still be
a part of part of that audience yeah so
we could go to state championships and
sell DVDs you know which we were only
gonna be able to go to a few of but it
you know it really helps that's our core
audience right there it's go go to them
you know we took our DVDs right to them
how many hours are you putting in behind
the scenes before each of these
screenings oh man that's a there's a lot
of work oh yeah
a ton of work cause we do all the
marketing ourselves I mean we you know
all the on you know online whatever you
know emailing a ton of writers I mean I
think that if you don't have PA money
that and this is what we learned on the
hip-hop Film Festival it's like those
sort of picked over the weeks it's that
sort of things in newspapers and
articles and newspapers really still
drive audiences to you like I know that
a lot of people say that that sort of
thing is dead but it I've seen it in our
films our experience is that like you
get real value out of being in the
newspaper like even just like on our
website we photocopy the newspaper
articles to prove that it was in a
newspaper like someone cared enough to
put this in print sort of you know what
I mean it's not just on online you know
so but there is value in that that you
know that pic of the week in a weekly
paper like the city paper in
Philadelphia that stuff really really
helps you know more so than ads I think
you know so we spend a lot of time
reaching out to writers sports writers
Foam writers and you know and it but you
risk getting bad reviews you know like
everybody else but but that's what we're
in this sure would you say that that's
the first thing then you would do if you
knew you were going to be in a certain
city is that the first plan of action is
to then go to that paper yeah to reach
out to writers and the wrestling
community film coaches like you know the
film wrestling organizations in that
area and and start from there and sort
of build off of that and then we go
there and hand out flyers and put up
posters and you know like like we were
talking about earlier it's really from
like underground hip hop kind of that
that like you know we just took it on
the road and promoting our CD but it's
our movie you know and and we see the
screenings s concerts and the paradigm
is simple to apply to film but you just
have to see your the you know your whole
experience of being a filmmaker in that
way if you don't want to do it then then
you know we all know filmmakers with
films on the Shelf like gosh I didn't
want to be one of those right so instead
of the rapper with the SUV you
tell me about it what do you have
planned as far as screens coming up do
you have anything No well we have it'll
be out on iTunes and Netflix like
sometime late this summer okay that that
we're hoping to get a release date
pretty soon and we'll start to push
really hard and then you know maybe do
some somewhere high school and college
screenings this fall leading up to
wrestling season again you know can you
know since you brought off the iTunes
and in Netflix how are you going about
getting on those platforms you know do
you have a distributor involved we yeah
we have a digital aggregate the orchard
that that Danny Kosta at the large films
hooked us up with and that that's who's
getting us on iTunes and and Netflix all
the digital platforms and you've sold
what 3000 plus DVDs is somewhere around
there wow that's incredible and how many
of these are online versus in person
maybe 50 50 somewhere probably a little
bit more online oh just just through our
website and it's all been through your
website yeah we there's a few like
wrestling apparel websites that carry it
but um not not too many you know there's
a bunch but we don't sell a ton through
those and how did you end up getting
sort of syndication with those like how
did you did you just send it a blind
query yeah yeah we have like a you know
a little one sheet or whatever that we
send out but in terms of the theatrical
run it's a lot of work you know and
we're talking about the amount of work
that it takes what why not get a
distributor involved to do all that work
for you because most distributors won't
do that for a film like this you know I
mean they're not going to do a
theatrical release they don't see the
value in it because they're overhead so
high you know two guys that can roll
around in hotel rooms is much cheaper
than then the whole like you know office
and Hollywood and staff and you know
what I mean so they just won't do it
you know and then for the DVD the the
offers we were
just weren't worth it to us it's like
why you know I mean I've seen I've shot
a lot of stuff I've seen a lot of
filmmakers never see a dime from their
films and going to big distributors and
small distributors and you know we're
talking about small films going to big
distributors or small distributors and
we're a small film and you know and we
found a way a paradigm that we could
have the film drive itself we you know
we put it on tour then we use that money
to manufacture DVDs we sell DVDs we use
that money to promote the film and then
sell some more and we just up converted
it to HD so now we have like the the
digital release is going to be in
high-definition
as opposed to the standard definition of
the DVD so it just started to pay for
itself on some level yeah and that's
that's really something that you've been
able to thing is taking so much hard
working so much energy but you've
actually traded this thing where through
that hard work you know you've got the
people to come out to the screenings
where the money enough money's come in
to actually grow and to build it where
you've been able to reinvest it the way
you're saying they're not not a lot of
people were able to make that happen now
they're not yeah it's tricky I mean it
Kirk has put in a lot of work you know
and you know we once we invent we
realize like this is the route we're
gonna go then we were then we're often
running and you know and it makes it
easy the subject matter of the film and
how determined needs people are and you
know makes it a little bit easier it's
like how can I give up
you know like look at the people on
screen look what they did for us you
know it's true yeah well it goes back to
what you said earlier is like you know
you gave up being filmmakers in a sense
to become the distributor's or building
your own platform and I think that's a
real key a lot of people don't realize I
hear so many people say oh I just want
to make art I don't want to have to be
involved in getting it out there I think
that's really crucial yeah I mean to me
there's nothing like sharing your work I
don't want to make films than sit at
home by myself okay it's really fun you
know screenings are really fun it's
really fun
it's nerve-wracking it's it's tense you
you know and it's incredible you know so
sharing it is what it's about to me so
in especially with an audience you know
like ten people you know a couple people
with the DVD it's nothing like 500
people in an audience or 50 people in an
audience you know it's it's a much
different experience and as an audience
member I like theatres better so I'm not
gonna default to DVDs as a filmmaker to
share to share my film if I can help it
not have to come in here and I do
because is this funny that you know
because I guess you got all sort of the
scary feelings and a nervous feelings
out way before you scream with us
because I got to say when we screamed at
the downtown independent you were as
poised that has come as any filmmaker
I've ever seen before the film you got
on the inside all that I saw was just
like man this guy is really confident
film like he knows it's a great film and
he's like alright let's go do it you
know and it was kind of it was really
great to see that right I'm not sure I
know it's a great film but I know it is
what it is you know and it and and I
have no excuses you know that and and
and so that's that's what we show it's
the film that we worked really hard on
and it's not the best film that ever was
but but we're proud of it you know and
so then it's kind of easy to share yeah
well I think it's an amazing film but I
like what you said about the no excuses
because it showed I mean you came in you
were humble you hustled and you went to
gyms you you followed up with wrestling
coaches and and you got this great
audience there and they were excited and
it's not an easy thing to do so our hats
off to you yeah thank you thank you and
I want to come back to the DVDs do you
think you would have been better off if
you could have had a point where you had
the DVDs from day one of the theatrical
release rather than at the tail end of
it when you had no more screenings would
you have been better off if you had the
DVDs of the very beginning and we're
selling DVDs and all those screenings
yeah for the wrestling season for sure
it would have been yeah and we would
have liked to have been but but we we
you know just financially we were just
in kind of timewise we just weren't able
to pull it off but that would be one
thing if you can go back you
would have the DVDs right away yeah yeah
we've we could have probably sold a lot
more if we were selling them at
screenings absolutely when you look up
takedowns and falls you know that the
film has a good amount of exposure yo
and you have a good Facebook Fenton like
what 3,500 or so yeah we have another
page that the one thing with Facebook I
hope I'm not gonna get our Central's
over but like you can't outreach with a
fan page right so we created that
takedowns person - okay so between the
two we have almost 6,000 you know
because those that that we use takedowns
that fake person that we created their
outreach to people and then when I can't
be fans of our page - some people do
some people don't but we basically use
both those pages the fan page and the
takedowns person to you know reach out
to people it's Facebook's only
suggesting people to you but then if you
ask too many they get mad at you you
know well so you you have that but then
we examine it closely we don't see a lot
of press on Todd Hickey and so it is
hard to find interviews with you as a
director of the film so the film is
really in the spotlight
whereas you remain more in the
background is this by design because I
think a lot of people would probably
like to be in that position in some
sense the work just speaks for itself it
yeah I don't like well I don't like
being in front of the camera that's why
I work behind the camera you know and I
want two films to speak for themselves I
don't you know I don't get a ton of joy
out of being front and center I think
that's how I relate to Walt in a lot of
ways is you know that it's not important
for me to be famous
I like making films you know I like the
experience it's in it and that's why I
do it you know and I guess the one
exception is being here on film courage
so yeah yeah that's interesting I know I
was it was a John Paul rice that came up
with the term the red carpet producer
the ones that love to walk the red
carpet but don't necessarily like to do
the work and it sounds like you're just
the opposite that you like to put in the
work and that the creation of it is what
gets you and sort of not not that that
spotlight you with the Facebook
how do you engage the audience you say
that you you put wrestling news and
things on there what do you find gets
the most response from the core group of
followers that's a good question
updates I guess current news like what's
current you know what's the most current
sort of like wrestling tournament you
know or sort of like what's happening to
the community in general rules changes
it really all depends there's so many
people on Facebook somebody's responding
to everything kind of you know so but I
like to that you're saying that you
engage them with news and it's not just
a one way feed that's all about the film
right well it's also just about you know
add as a friend friends are suspended
for three days and on the fan page you
can't do that on this fake person we can
you know it's just like suggesting you
know every day it's 10:00 or every
minute whatever there's 10 people in
wrestling uniforms on the side you may
know this person maybe we do I think
people are gonna enjoy that little
little tidbit there and what are your
overall thoughts on social media I mean
you spend a lot of time there
um Kirk does most of the work on on the
Twitter and Facebook I don't spend a lot
of time on there I just started to
recently I mean I just recently got my
own Facebook page because people were
sort of leading personal messages and
takedowns and falls and I don't want to
clutter the - you know thing so I mean I
spend more time on it now just posting
stupid pictures best thing we hope to
hear more about Todd Hickey thank you
listen we've been speaking with
cinematographer writer director producer
Todd Hickey for more on Todd please
visit takedowns and falls comm and also
on Facebook at the takedowns and Falls
page you can also connect with Todd on
Twitter at resilient pics and that's p.i
CS and thank you again thank you so much
guys I appreciate your support
you know we knew this one was going to
be great coming in and it lived up to
those notations yeah thank you so much
talking I think thank you for joining us
on another Sunday edition of film
courage we look forward to being here
with you next Sunday at noon on Le talk
radio calm we're gonna be joined by
filmmaker Alex Ferrari someone who we
met in person for the first time at the
Hawley Short Film Festival several years
ago you may know his work broken sin and
red princess blues for more on Alex
please visit Alex Ferrari comm and a
shout out to our wonderful guy Ron and
Rosner as always he does so much for us
he is our radio angel as well as the
architect behind film courage calm and
until next Sunday have a great week